el presidente bucl se ha agenciado una
contundente victoria electoral según
resultados preliminares brindados por el
tribunal supremo electoral los partidos
afines al mandatario nuevas ideas y la
gran alianza nacional obtendrían
alrededor de 60 diputados con lo que
alcanzarían la mayoría absoluta dentro
del parlamento esto les daría vía libre
entre otras cosas para avanzar sin
ningún impedimento en sus intenciones de
reformar la constitución de la república
al mismo tiempo el oficialismo
gobernaría en las principales alcaldías
del país el nuevo congreso y los nuevos
consejos municipales entrarán en
funciones a partir de mayo próximo hasta
el 2024 año en que finaliza también la
gestión gubernamental por su parte los
partidos tradicionales a los que buque
le llama los mismos de siempre quedaron
bastante reducidos y en sus primeras
declaraciones han manifestado que
mantendrán una férrea pero constructiva
oposición de momento el mandatario no ha
aparecido públicamente para celebrar
este triunfo
y sólo lo he hecho exactamente desde sus
redes sociales